Das Podcast Ufo, der beste Podcast, wir haben auch nicht. Herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr da seid zu dieser fantastischen neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO mit Stefan Tietze. Und vorhin und vielen Dank an Marcel für dieses Intro, der uns verzaubert hat mit dieser Melange aus Klängen und Rhythmen. So hat man sich in den 70ern die Zukunft vorgestellt, glaube ich.
Und 2000 wird man sich so die Vergangenheit vorstellen,
als wir mit Lauten diese Elektromusik produzieren.
Diese Future-Brillen, die noch nicht am Start sind, ein bisschen, Oculus Rift und so weiter.
Halt dieses Mr. Data von Star Trek, heisst der so, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ja, es gab doch auch Google Glasses irgendwie, wo nochmal über die ganze Welt so eine neue Ebene gelegt wurde, wo du zu jeder Person die Lebenspunkte sehen konntest, Schwachstelle irgendwie, aber hat sich auch nicht durchgesetzt. Es wurde prinzipiell nur über die Welt das neue Tuch gelegt, es wird irgendwann mal Google Glass geben und seitdem warten wir alle gespannt drauf, es wurde so ein Tuch der Anspannung über uns gelegt. Die eigentliche Google Glass ist die Google Glass der Vorfreude, die es noch nicht gibt, Aber ist das nicht die Zukunft? Aber wenn Google weiss, Vorfreude ist die liebste Freude wahrscheinlich, weiss Google ja als Suchmaschine, als die Seite, die auf alles eine Antwort hat. Also in dem Sinne vielen Dank. Ich finde auch, Google sollte jetzt rausbringen, hey, es gibt Mandy, das ist dein persönlicher Assistenzroboter, der ist winzig klein, der ist klein wie ein Flaschenkorken, der macht alles für dich, der macht deine Hausaufgaben, der ruft für dich beim Arzt an, Release 2081. Aber ey, freut euch auf Mandy, das ist so ein Akronym für Manuel, Android, Never Ending. Für Manuel, Manuel, Android. Aber 2081 kommt raus, aber alle sagen in der Tat, wie Stefan Tietze damals sagte, Vorfreude ist die schönste Freude, ich kann mein Leben nicht glauben. Das ist unfassbar gerade. Wie Logician Stefan Tietze. Logician? Du bist Logician? Ja genau, habe ich da nicht so einen TED-Talk geguckt, aber diese animierten, diese kurzen, nicht die, wo ich ernsthaft, wo das ernsthaft meine Aktivität wäre, mir in 15 Minuten einen Vortrag einzugucken, nein. Mir reichen ja diese kleinen animierten, toll gesprochenen Snippets, die sind klein, die sind handlich, die sind wegsnackbar. Ich mag von denen nochmal die wiederum gekürzten Highlighter. Die Trailer. Mag ich auch, finde ich auch super, balleie ich mir weg. Und da wurde jemand vorgestellt, dass der Logiker Göbel oder Gödel oder sowas und mir gefiel diese Berufsbezeichnung. Logiker ist geil, ja. Weil bin ich auf eine Art, würde ich mich so, würde ich mich wiederfinden. Niemand hält dich davon ab, dich Logiker zu nennen. Die Logiker sind relativ schwach in der Durchsetzung ihrer Berufsbezeichnung. Ja, auch so schwach, dass ich es nicht schützen, diesen Begriff. Auch körperlich schwarz. Würden die dich angreifen, könntest du die locker mit einer Hand von dir fernhalten. Nein, nein, jetzt unterschätzt du mir die Logika. Ja? Du unterschätzt mir, glaube ich, ich weiss Sternchen, die Logika, weil die können sich ja mit ihrem messerscharfen Verstand rauswinden aus jeder Seite. Wenn ich wütend, dann du Problem. Oder so, die kommen dann mit ihren ganz logischen Formeln. Und ich sitze dann erst mal da und verfallere in Gedanken, passiv und kann nicht mich rühren aus der Situation. Ich habe ja tatsächlich in meinem Studium hatte ich ja eine Logikvorlesung, das gehört dazu, da musst du dann so Sachen machen wie wenn A dann B und wenn B dann C, gleich wenn A dann C, halt solche Geschichten. Gleich hat keinerlei Korrelationen. Ja, und dann irgendwie solche Geschichten. Und das einzige, woran ich mich noch erinnere aus der gesamten Vorlesungsreihe, ich glaube drei Semester oder so, war, dass von unserem Professor gab es ein Video online. Und es ist ja eigentlich so, wie wenn man jemanden auf Tinder matcht oder so geht, man ja erst mal auf Google und googelt alles über die Person. Genauso ist es bei Professoren auch. Und er hatte so ein Video, so eine Reportage, die ihn begleitet,
weil er war irgendein absolutes Genie, der irgendwie auch wahnsinnig viel Geld bekommen hat dafür,
dass er seinen Logikkram da forscht.
War er Logiker?
Er war Logiker, er hatte Logikvorlesungen gegeben.
Professor Doktor Locke?
Nee, es war nicht Locke, Leitgeb hieß der, kann ich vielleicht mal sagen,
Shoutout an der Stelle, absolut krasser Typ. Professor Doktor Locke, wie Dent Zahn ist, haben die denn so einen Logiker-Doktor? Ja, das kann sein, das weiß ich nicht. Und der hatte so eine Doku über ihn, wo er gezeigt wurde, und da wurde er in der Münchner U-Bahn gezeigt, mit dem Zitat, die besten Ideen kommen hier zwischen den Stationen. Und dieses Zitat hat sich bei uns... Wir haben eine Station so, we're standing right here. Ja, genau. Odeonsblatt so, was ist ein scheiß Problem? Gämmering. Und dann hat sich das wie ein Lauffeuer bei uns verbreitet. Und ich weiß noch, wir haben eine Logikklausur irgendwann geschrieben, wo man selber einen Beispielsatz wählen sollte. Denken Sie sich einen Beispielsatz aus und legen Sie dann an dem Satz irgendwie irgendwas aus. Keine Ahnung. Und fast der gesamte Studiengang hat den Satz, die besten Ideen kommen mit Zwischeninstitutionen, als Beispielsatz genommen. Ich als Logikstudent würde sagen, Moment, mein Messerschlagerverstand sagt mir, dass er nicht will, dass man sich darüber lustig macht. Weiß ich nicht. Denn das ist logisches Verhalten. Naja, Comedy ist ja auch eine Form von Logik, von Puzzle, von Wort. Aber wenn er achtmal diesen gleichen Drecksatz, der sich über ihn lustig macht, mit den lustigen Karikaturen auf dem Löschblatt sieht, dann Löschblatt auch, oh, Wahnsinn. Ja, später haben wir herausgefunden, dass er keine einzige Klausur korrigiert hat, sondern dass irgendwelche anderen Leute gemacht haben. Naja, aber das war mein Studium. Ich fände es spannend, was mit mir hängen geblieben ist von meinem zwei Minuten zehn Snippet war der Satz, dieser Satz ist falsch.
So, anhand dieses Sätzes hat nämlich Herr Gödel, weil der Satz ist nämlich spannend, weil die Sprache kann was, was die Mathematik nicht kann, sich selbst widersprechen.
Dieser Satz ist falsch, ist, wenn es falsch ist, nicht falsch, und wenn es richtig ist, falsch. Heißt, dieser Satz ist in sich, hat der, der macht sich kaputt. Das reicht, um Logiker zu sein, und das, also das reicht jetzt für dich, du hast den Orden bekommen. Nee, jetzt geht es noch weiter. Genau, jetzt geht es noch weiter, aber nicht viel weiter. Wir sind fast am Ziel. Wir sind fast am Ziel. Ohne Scheiß? Wir sind fast am Ziel. Wenn man von Dortmund nach Köln fährt, sind wir in fucking Rämischheit. Wir sind fast da. Okay. Wir können schon mal aufstehen und schon mal demonstrativ vor die Türen stellen, um den anderen den Weg zu verpassen. Ehrlich, ihr müsst nicht mal die Folge zu Ende hören. Wenn ihr jetzt aufhört und schlafen geht, ihr habt nichts verfasst, weil wir sind echt ohne Scheiß fast da.
Skipp, skipp weiter.
Also, und Mathematik kann das nicht sich selbst widersprechen.
Wenn du sagst, eins ist gleich zwei?
Das ist falsch, einfach eine falsche Aussage.
Okay.
Aber du kannst nicht mit einem ja komplett richtiger Grammatik und richtigen Satz, sondern hat er irgendwie diesen ganzen Satz in Formeln übersetzt, dieser Gödel oder ich habe den Namen vergessen und hat dann versucht, das Ganze auf Mathematik zu übertragen.
Hat es geklappt oder nicht? Ich meine ja. Ihr fahrt es in der nächsten Folge von Dingen, die ich mal gesehen habe und mich nicht mehr wirklich daran erinnern kann. oder war es ein Traum?
Beim Sprechen ist mir eingefallen, nämlich, dass er dann dazu geführt hat, dass es seitdem in der Mathematik Aussagen gibt, die hinlänglich und komplett verifiziert werden können. Also zum einen kann man sagen, ja, das stimmt komplett, aber es gibt auch einfach manche Theoreme in der Mathematik, die kann man nicht komplett unterstützen, da muss es reichen. Die kann man nicht komplett verifizieren. Die armen Logiker, die gerade zuhören und sich einfach vergraben, gerade vor Scham, wie ihren Berufsstand durch den Dreck ziehen. Ja, ich habe dich übrigens gerade in einer sehr privaten Situation erlebt. Ich weiß nicht, ob du mich gesehen hast, ich habe dich gesehen, auch wie du auf der Straße hergelaufen bist. Was man, wenn man verabredet ist, nicht sehen will, ist wie mit 80 Stundenkilometern die Person, mit dem verabredet ist, an einem vorbeiführt in die falsche Richtung, in so einem kleinen Car-to-go, Licht an, Blinker an, Scheibenwischer an. Die Wasserspritzanlage auf die Winchetscheibe. Ich glaube, ich habe dich, aber das ist das erste Mal, dass ich dich wirklich völlig privat normal gesehen habe, dass wir nicht zusammen irgendwo waren, sondern du wirklich in deiner, in normalem Habitat. Ich konnte noch nicht meine Performance-Mode anschalten. Dafür war ich keine Zeit, weil du auf mich zugerasst bist. Wie gehe ich? Ich gehe merkwürdig. Du gehst schon merkwürdig, du hast einen riesigen Rucksack, ist mir sonst nicht aufgefallen, der liegt hier immer daneben, aber an deinem Körper wirkt der wirklich wie so ein Yoda, der einfach dich einmal umklammert und man sich denkt, wie kann der das Gleichgewicht halten? Kao, barely. Ja, aber ich habe dich gegrüsst und mir ist dabei aufgefallen, es gibt ein frappantes Machtungleichgewicht zwischen Erstgrüsser und Zweitgrüsser. Der Erstgrüsser, cool, souverän, hey, was geht? Der Zweitgrüsser guckt erst mal verwirrt, wer war das, woher kenne ich dich? Der stellt sich viele Fragen. Der Erste sieht es, also alles Unangenehme ist davor. Der Erste grüße auch allein schon diese Macht zu haben, vielleicht auch nicht zu grüßen. Richtig. Entscheiden zu können, wird gegrüßt, ja oder nein? Warum hast du dich entschieden, mich nicht zu grüßen? Weil ich hab dich nicht angeguckt. Man sieht auch Leute im Auto nicht sitzen. Da ist die große The Barrier of Glass. Ich glaube, das ist sogar noch mal eine höhere Stufe des Machtgefälles zwischen Erstgrüsser und Zweitgrüsser, wenn der Erstgrüsser im Auto sitzt. Und einfach, ich grüße gerne, ich grüße gerne. Manchmal gebe ich zu, grüße ich Leute, die ich nicht kenne. Einfach Leute, die aus dem Zebrastreifen gehen und ich einfach Hand hoch und die Person, einfach um diesen konfusen Blick einmal einzufangen. Ich mach das gern. Das ist meine Form von Machtmissbrauch des Erstgrüssers. Und du hast nicht so gegrüsst, verwirrter Blick, konfus, vor allem dann noch so dieser panische Blick über die Schulter. Wer war das eigentlich? Das ist mein kleines Paradies, mein kleines Alltagsparadies. Du hast es geschafft. Viel zu spät gesehen, viel zu spät reagiert, nur an so eine ruckartige Bewegung innerhalb eines Autos gedacht, ah, war das vielleicht ein Grüßen. Und dann habe ich reagiert und du warst aber schon in diesem Suffisanten, beide Hände am Lenkrad, ich habe gerade meine Machtmissbrauch grinsen und bist dann weggefahren an mir. Deswegen mein Tipp an alle Zweitgrüsser, einfach grüssen, einfach zurück, direkt zurückgrüssen, es lohnt sich nicht, reflexartig zu evaluieren, kenne ich den, ja, oh, woher, schon zu spät, einfach wenn ich immer grüße, instant zurückgrüssen und dann kannst du ja danach immer noch verwirrt und dusselig in die Luft gucken, wer das war. Es bleibt genug Zeit, um den Rest des Tages zu gucken. Du kannst grübeln, du kannst gucken, du kannst googeln, mach was du willst, aber in dem Moment erstmal zurückgrüssen, Hand hoch. Wohin? Weil ich glaube, viel dieses Wartens, dusselig gucken, ist erstmal erörtern, wo kommt denn überhaupt der Gruß her. Moment, das heißt, du weißt, du wurdest gegrüsst, aber nicht woher. Naja, wenn jemand so eine Art, wie wenn so ein Scharfschütze schießt und du erstmal nicht weißt, wohin. Und ich erstmal wissen will, von wo wurde ich jetzt erschossen. Ja, genau. Ach gut, aber du redest jetzt von verbalem Gruss. Ich rede kurz von, hey Stefan! Ja, von unserem Wahrscheinlichkeitsbaum bin ich abgedriftet in die Ecke des verbalen Grüssens. Aber, ich stelle die Regel auf, man darf Leute nur grüssen, mit denen man auf einer Höhe ist. Du meinst deine Fans, die dir die hundert Stockwerke unter dir irgendwo ihr erbärmliches Leben führen, von denen reden wir jetzt nicht. Erstens das, also mit Schmutz rede ich nicht erstmal, aber zweitens auch, wenn einer im ersten Stock ist, auf dem Balkon, der andere auf dem Boden. Ich meine wirklich Höhe, ich rede wirklich von Nautisch Null, Höhe über dem Meeresspiegel. Ja, ja, komm du mir mal mit nautisch null. Wenn jemand aus dem Balkon grüsst, ist es verboten, weil der andere hat keine Chance. Der andere guckt sich um und ist verloren und du kommst nicht auf die, die noch nach oben zu gucken. Das darf man einfach nicht. Da ist der Machtmissbrauch wirklich zu gross. Nur Grüssen auf einer Ebene, wenn man die andere die Chance hat, überhaupt nicht zu finden. Mir gefällt das. Mach mal so ein Bild von Florentin, und da drunter schreibt er dann, Machtmissbrauch okay, aber in geringem Maße. Ja, aber in Maßen. Na klar, natürlich, alles in Maßen. Das ist ja in Ordnung, aber nicht von oben oder auch nicht von unten, gilt dasselbe. Machtmissbrauch sind wie Chips in Maßen okay. Ja. Machtmissbrauch ist wie Alkohol. Und gegen Ende wird es auch immer weirder, weil die Hände immer schmutziger werden und du dich immer tiefer in die Tüte reingraben musst. Vielleicht bleibt sogar deine Hand in der Pringles-Dose stecken. Wer weiß. Wer weiß das schon. Und dann ist es Fifty-Fifty zwischen cool, ich bin Mega Man und oh fuck, ich komme nicht an meine Chips ran. Ja, das Plakat ist voll, seit einer halben Stunde. Ach, okay. Wir haben nicht so viel Platz. Okay, dann machen wir es kürzer, dann machen wir Machtmissbrauch, okay, aber nur ein bisschen, weil sonst muss man zum Beispiel mit der Colorado-Tüte auch dieses weirde, harte Zeug. Wir machen Machtmissbrauch okay, okay? Ja, okay, lass uns das mal. Lass uns einfach nur das mal. Einfach deine grinsende Fresse und dann so Machtmissbrauch ist okay. Ich meine, gerade ist Wahlkampf und ich bin wie jedes Jahr, bin auf jedes Jahr enttäuscht, wie unkreativ die Plakate sind, aber müssen sie natürlich nicht, die ist nicht die Aufgabe, kreativ zu sein, aber du kannst dich ja austoben. Ich fände es geil, weil da sind ja oft nur so ganz wenig Worte, so Veränderung jetzt! Und du denkst dir, ja Mann, klar! Geil fände ich auch, wenn da einfach so in ganz kleiner Schrift so dieses gesamte Plakat von oben bis unten mit Text runtergeschrieben ist so.
Natürlich, die Zeiten sind schwer, wir dürfen aber trotzdem nicht den Blick aufs große Ganze verlieren,
weil im Grunde muss man natürlich jetzt Entscheidungen treffen, die in 50 Jahren an Früchte tragen werden. Und dann so super pathetisch, dann unten in grosser Schrift, wir haben zu viel Inhalt für kleine Wahlplakate.
Yes, finde ich gut. Ja, finde ich gut. Unsere Politik passt nicht auf ein Plakat.
Ja, zu viele Ideen für ein Plakat. Das ist gar nicht so doof eigentlich. Das ist gar nicht so dumm. Mach das! Können wir mal eine Werbefirma aufmachen und dann sofort wieder zumachen? Ich habe letztens eine Doku gesehen von irgendeinem Millionär, der ungefragt Werbung für die AfD gemacht hat. Der fand die halt cool und hat einfach sein eigenes Geld in die Hand genommen, um eine Plakatkampagne zu machen. Und ich wusste ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, dass man das darf. Man kann alles. Dass ich jetzt einfach irgendwo zu einem Plakatfirma hingehe und sage, mach mal ein Plakat für die Partei. Nee, das glaube ich nicht. Nee, aber du musst ja irgendwo die Plakate aufhängen. Aber die AfD sagt ja nicht, oh, sie wollen uns eine Million Euro spenden, na gut, da müssen wir erstmal ein paar bürokratische Hürden durchlaufen. Die sagt ja wahrscheinlich sofort, ja klar.
Aber wenn ich jetzt einfach zu einer Plakatfirma hingehe, die Plakate aufhängt und sage, hier hängen Sie bitte das Plakat auf für die SPD, sagen die dann, nein, dürfen wir nicht? Ja klar, wir brauchen erst die Erlaubnis von der SPD. Das kann ja auch ein AfD-Hajopal sein, mit einer SPD-Mütze aufgesetzt, der dann drauf schreibt, Dussel, Dussel, Dusselköppe. Und dann einfach, das ist ja auch gemeint gegenüber der SPD.
Ja, das ist gemeint.
Das wäre echt gemein. Mach das nicht. Das wäre gemein. Aber vielleicht habe ich es auch missverstanden, dass der einfach der AfD Geld gegeben hat. Aber so wie ich es verstanden habe, hat er mehr oder weniger auf eigene Faustwirbung gemacht. Kann man ja machen. Vielleicht kann man es nicht machen. Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube nicht für andere.
Der Logiker in mir sagt, dass es wahrscheinlich... Man darf für sich seine eigene Parteiwerbe machen.
Höchstwahrscheinlich ist es verboten.
Leicht es denn, wenn ich in der Partei bin?
Nee, hör einfach jetzt auf, diese Plakate zu betrachten.
Aber wenn ich in der Partei bin und Werbeplakate für mich selbst mache, das kann mir ja niemand nehmen.
Nee, aber stehst du denn zur Wahl?
Ich kann doch Werbung für mich selbst machen. Stehst du denn zur Wahl, aber du beschmutzt ja den guten SPD-Namen. Den so guten Namen. Ich kann doch Werbung für mich selber machen. Ja, klar, das sage ich ja nur, aber zieht ja unsere Firmennamen nicht durch den Dreck. Wenn du gecancelt wirst, ist die SPD gleich mitcancelt. Das heißt, wir können ja ein Wahlplakat machen, Tietze und Will, und unten Tietze distanziert sich. Und dann halt nur Will. Vielleicht sowas. Ja, Will. Ich finde es aber, du hast schon recht, das mit der Werbung macht mich seit Jahren rasend. Auch diese Werbesports im Fernsehen. Wirklich rasend? Du sahst nicht rasend aus, als ich dich heute gesehen habe. Ja, stimmt. Es lässt mich eher mit so einem ... Zurück. Mit einem gemütlichen ... Ja, ja. So, aber ich verstehe, was du meinst. Auch allein so im Fernsehen, man will ja schon eigentlich die ... Dass da mal mehr passiert. Ich habe das Gefühl, in den USA ist es doch irgendwie krasser, was da unterwegs ist. Gehen wir dann so mit Cambridge Analytics und so. Wo ist die SPD und CDU bei Cambridge Analytics, wo sind die Grünen, die so krasse Hacker beauftragen, um Wahlwerbung krass zu platzieren. Ja, das stimmt. Wo ist Anonymous, wo sind die denn alle? In Amerika, die machen in Amerika den Wahlkampf mit, weil er spannender ist, weil Amerika wichtiger ist. Aber ich meine, die müssen doch auch üben, oder? Also angenommen, du bist jetzt so ein Hacker-Kollektiv aus Russland oder was, du, bevor du jetzt den großen amerikanischen US-Wahlkampf manipulierst, gehst du ja erstmal, ey, übrigens nächste Woche Botswana, wollen wir nicht da mal... Ich wollte gerade sagen, du übst dann eher in so einem kleinen, überschaubaren Rahmen. Genau, du übst einfach mal, lass uns die mal manipulieren, irgendwie da gibt es also einen weirden Typen von der Gummistiefelpartei, die einfach sagen, Leute, im Ernst, wenn jeder ein paar Gummistiefel hat, geht es uns allen besser, lasst uns erstmal das Problem lösen. Und die sagen, er, lass uns den gewinnen. Und dann gewinnt der und dann sagen sie, okay, jetzt wissen wir, wie es geht. Dabei hat er nur diese Gummistiefel-Lobby im Rücken. Stimmt, ja. Und er ist eigentlich der Schwager von dem Besitzer dieser Rundfunkfabrik. Woher weißt du denn immer solche Sachen? Du bist immer so gut informiert. Ich dachte, die Botswana ist am Arsch. Die sind auf diesen Typen reingefallen. Die sind jetzt am Arsch. Und wie genau erfahrt ihr in der Kategorie Antenna? Nein! Ich habe mal als Kind tatsächlich Wahlplakate abgerissen und da habe ich richtig Ärger bekommen. Von? Richtig Ärger. Vom System? Vom System? The man, the man called. Fuck the system, the system fucked me. Wie? How? Ne, ich habe richtig Ärger bekommen, weil das ist ja ein ernstes Verbrechen, das geht ja über Vandalismus hinaus, da war so eine große Wand. Leicht. Ja, aber geht raus. Jetzt waren so eine große, so 102 Prozent, aber es ist technisch gesehen drüber.
Es war so eine große Wand mit verschiedenen Wahlplakaten und ich habe manche davon abgerissen. Rückblickend weiß ich nicht mehr genau, was ich versucht habe, politisch zu erreichen. Also wollte ich eine Partei den Sieg gönnen, wollte ich Wahlwerbung manipulieren oder wollte ich einfach nur Dinge kaputt machen? Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau. Hast du eine übergelassen oder hast du eine abgerissen? Ich war erst mal erstaunt.
Ich habe ein Wahlplakat abgerissen und fand darunter ein weiteres Wahlplakat. Des gleichen Modells? Einer anderen Partei. Die schon bereits da hing? Und an dem Punkt, Moment mal, die überkleben sich gegenseitig die Wahlplakate, jetzt muss ich eingreifen, jetzt bin ich gefragt. und reisst jetzt so lange Wahlplakate, bis der Ursprung der Kohl-Wahlkampf von 1986 da hängt und einfach die Original-O-G's da mal wieder rauskommen und einfach diese zwei Meter dicke Papierschicht. Deswegen hat Cole 2006 ein paar Stimmen bekommen in Ebersberg, muss man auch mal sagen. Stimmt, und er hat auch kurz überlegt, ob er es nochmal macht, ob er nochmal in den Stadtrat geht.
Fuck it.
Einfach sagt, warum nicht. Aber da habe ich richtig Ärger bekommen. Da kamen richtig hohe Leute. Da kamen richtig hohe Leute. In den Brüssel in Flagranti erwischt, mit dem Ballpark hat er noch Hand und dann mit den Knibbelfingern? So halb Flagranti auf jeden Fall. Ich konnte mich ganz gut rausreden mit Ich habe nur die runtergerissen, die beschädigt waren. Was tatsächlich super funktioniert hat als Ausrede. Aber da habe ich richtig Ärger bekommen. Also richtig, da kam richtig der Hammer der Justiz aus dem fünften Stock auf mich heruntergefahren. Aber jetzt führe mich genau durch die Situation. Wurdest du an dem Tatort erwischt? Ich wurde erwischt mit einem guten Kumpel von mir, den ich jetzt decke. Den Namen habe ich vor Gericht nicht preisgegeben. I ain't no snitch. Und deswegen decke ich ihn auch weiter. Du weißt, wer du bist. Du weißt auch, dass du dich mal dafür revanchieren kannst, für diese Tat, kameradschaftliche Tat. Und wir haben das runtergerissen und dann kam jemand. Schwarze Vans. Kam jemand, also wirklich Justitia persönlich, hat ihr Schwert gezogen und uns mit einem Streich, mit einem Schwertstreich, mit einem Todesstoss, mit einem Paragraphen-Todesstoss uns wirklich zum Teufel gejagt. Also anders kann man es sich beschreiben. Wir waren erledigt, wir waren bedient, wir waren erledigt. Es war kein schöner Anblick und wir haben richtig fucking Ergobacht bekommen. Deswegen, du bist so innerlässt der wieder Wahlkampf. Deswegen an der Stelle, liebe Leute da draußen, die Verlockung ist gross. Ihr seht ein Wahlplakat, das euch inhaltlich und oder von Design nicht gefällt. Ja, und ich habe auch noch nicht gehört, warum ich sie machen soll. Und weil ihr dann, also ihr kriegt richtig von ganz, ganz oben richtig Ärger. Reißt sie nicht runter, sondern stellt euch davor. Stellt euch einfach mit eurem wulstigen Körper davor. Die meisten Menschen haben einen Körper, mit dem man ein Wahlplakat recht gut verdecken kann. Ja, man muss sich auf den Leiter stellen oder auf den Stuhl. Aber man kann sich schon davor stellen. Ja, was ist, wenn so eine Klappleiter... Ist das verboten? Werden Leute eigentlich beeinflusst durch fucking Plakate? Wahrscheinlich 100%. Wahrscheinlich entscheidet das die Wahl. Ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Ist es verboten, sich vor ein Wahlplakat zu stellen? Ist das Wahl... Ich glaube, da kommen auf die Zeit an. Hilfe zum Wahlbetrug. Ich würde abraten, ich würde es euch abraten, ihr wisst, was ich damals erlebt habe, und das wünsche ich keinem, das wünsche ich meinem ärgsten Feind nicht, und deswegen macht das auf gar keinen Fall, sondern versucht auf einem anderen Wege den politischen Willen eurer Mitmenschen zu beeinflussen, wie zum Beispiel sinnlose Gespräche. Sinnlose Gespräche. Top drei Momente, für die du am meisten Ärger bekommen hast. Was soll ich da anfangen? Also da, ich bin ja, sag ich mal, kein einfaches Kind gewesen. Also da prasselte es durchaus manchmal die harte Peitsche der Gerechtigkeit. Wie cool wäre es, wenn ich jetzt deine Brüder vorher angerufen hätte und wüsste, wofür du am meisten Ärger bekommen hast und jetzt dann so einen Spieler hätte. Das wäre richtig geil. Das wäre richtig gut. Aber so weit ist der Podcast noch nicht. Von meinen Brüdern würden sagen, der Typ ist verdammt langweilig, der macht gar nichts. Und vor allem für die schlimmsten Sachen wurde ich nicht erwischt. Also Platz 1 wird auf jeden Fall natürlich dann diese unschöne Wahlplakatsache, ne? Klar. Das ist auf 1, muss auf 1. Muss auf 1. Also mit großem Abstand. Platz 3, ich glaube, ich habe richtig Ärger mal nach einem Elternabend bekommen, als meine Mutter mir gesagt hat, du störst so sehr im Unterricht, dass dein Lehrer in Erwägung gezogen hat, dich nicht mit auf die Klassenfahrt zu nehmen. Das ist die krasste Drohung, die man aussprechen kann. Ich dachte mir, holy shit, das ist die schlimmste. Aber da hat der Lehrer wirklich seine einzige Waffe, den einzigen Hebel, den er hat nach Noten, soziale Ausgrenzung gezückt. Ja, im Grunde schon. Ich habe vor allem, ich dachte mir, okay, jetzt ist es ernst. Bis jetzt waren es kleine Penela-Scherze, bis jetzt war es kleine Zettelchen im Klassenraum rumreichen. Aber jetzt wird es fucking ernst. Wir sind auf der Ebene der Klassenfahrt. Und was machen Leute, die zu Hause bleiben in einer Klassenfahrt? Gehen die in eine andere Klasse dann?
Nee, ich dachte, du kannst zu Hause bleiben. Wie so ein, hey, der Florentin war zu dumm, um mit auf die Klassenfahrt zu kommen, der hat zu sehr gestört. Meine erste Frage wäre, Sir, man muss nicht mit zur Klassenfahrt? Man muss nicht diesem sozialen Druck, dieser schwitzigen Busfahrt? Nein, wenn du so weitermachst, kommst du nicht mit. und dann hätte ich so einen Zettel genommen und dem Lehrer in den Kopf geworfen.
Weil eigentlich ist doch die Klassenfahrt das Ultime. Gut, man kann sagen, das sind doch Erlebnisse, die einen formen. Aber das sind doch die sozial furchtbarsten. Ich weiß noch, diese Aufregung, als dann die Bustür aufregen mit diesem Tüff, diesem erbarmungslosen Höllengeräusch. Dieses Geräusch schrecklich. Dann geht man da rein und diese Angst halten sich alle an die Absprechungen, neben wem gesessen wird.
Halten Sie sich bitte. Wenn einer sich nicht daran hält, haben wir ein Riesenproblem.
Es ist eine Aneinanderreihung von politischen Diskussionen und die Frage, wird es eingehalten oder nicht.
Es sind politische Bündnisse, erstens, wo sitzt man im Bus, zweitens, wer geht mit wem ins Zimmer.
Und da lernt man eigentlich mehr über Politik, als man in jeder Folge Markus Lanz lernen könnte. Du musst nämlich, ja, Staffel 1 war die beste. Du musst jedenfalls auch von Anfang an Werbung für dich machen, natürlich, das ist natürlich eine Art Ohnitz-Wahlplakade. Ich habe einen Gameboy. Ich rieche nicht unangenehm. Ich habe drei Flaschen Deo dabei, zwei können wir anzünden, eine nutze ich, um meinen pubertierenden Körper unter Kontrolle zu halten. Ich mag, sie reflektiert unsere Jugendlichen sind. Ich habe diese Saskia-Quell-Lidl-Flasche, da habe ich Bärensen-Saurerapfel reingefüllt. Das Getränk, was wir besonders mögen, obwohl es leckerere gibt. Ich habe die Handynummer von Chiara. Ich, Chiara und ich haben uns mal an den Händen berührt. Wo? Das war eine Lüge. Okay, du bist raus. Und dann, wenn du die Bündnisse geschlossen hast, ist ja die Frage, halten die Bündnisse die Busfahrt hinüber, halten die Busfahrt die verschiedenen Körperöffnungslehrungen, die stattfinden
auf so einer Busfahrt, inwiefern
verändern die nochmal die politischen Verhältnisse?
Schwierig, die Mehrheitsverhältnisse ganz, ganz schwierig.
Aber wird doch immer besser, oder?
Ich habe das Gefühl, die Jugendlichen werden doch total
auf meinet cool.
Ich bin ein großer Fan, ich weiß, ich glaube, es gehört
eigentlich mit dazu, dass man immer die Jugendlichen verachten
muss, egal in welcher Epoche man lebt.
Nicht mehr wir. Aber nee, ich glaube, das kippt. Ich glaube, für den Jugendlichen echt super. Ich bin letztens schön mit so einem Elektroroller hingefallen. Nein, nein, nein. Und dann das zweite Mal in meinem Leben. Das erste Mal wurde es im Fernsehen übertragen. Was? Das zweite Mal hat es eine Gruppe Jugendlicher gesehen. Und die waren sofort da und hey, alles cool, können wir dir helfen? Und ich so, nee, alles okay, alles cool.
Wo bist du hingefallen? Direkt vorne im Edeka, einfach direkt, ich wollte da so cool, weil da war so eine Traube Jugendlicher und ich musste an den
und ich wollte so ein cooles Schlingermanöver machen, und dann bin ich halt voll ...
Oh mein Gott.
Und dann mussten die dieses Lachen verknallen.
Nein, null. Die waren super helfsbereit und so, ey, alles okay, alles cool.
So wirklich so der aus der Gruppe, von der man erwarten würde, dass der so das Wort ergleit. Aber will man nicht jetzt, dass die dann unangenehm sind, damit du zumindest noch die emotionale Reife hast, aber du hast in allen Ebenen da gerade sozial verloren. Ja, absolut. Die sind sozial, du warst weggelaufen, auch hast weggeguckt und hättest es dann nicht gesehen. Ja, oder auslachen, so auch okay. Wenn du dich auslacht, dann ah, okay, blöd gelaufen.
Aber es ist noch demütigender, wenn alles normal cool läuft eigentlich.
Du bist jetzt der ultimative Lappen in dieser Situation gewesen.
Deutlich älter als die.
Die sind wahnsinnig reif, auch schon so sozial.
Ich meine, ich bin für die so tief, dass sie mich nicht mehr auslachen.
Ja, tritt wenigstens auf mich noch drauf.
Ja, tritt mich drauf, ich kann das schon aushalten.
Dann bin ich ein Ziel.
Dann bin ich sozial im Konkurrenten.
Weil bei den Klassenkameraden von denen hinfallen würden die lachen.
Ich bin für die zu alt.
Ich bin für die wie so ein alter Mann, der aus dem Auto fällt.
Da lacht man auch nicht.
Wenn sie hinfallen, ist es auch nicht mehr...
Haben die sich gesiezt auch?
Ja.
Das war nicht mehr lustig, weil es auch gefährlich sein kann.
Weil sie können sich was tun,
und das können sie dann nicht mehr reparieren. Lassen Sie sich lieben mal Röntgen, auch wenn Sie jetzt gerade nicht spüren, wir haben das im Sozialkundeunterricht gelernt, dass Leute von älteren Alltag vielleicht mal, also wirklich, wir kommen gerne mit. Wir kommen auch gerne mit. Wir kommen gerne mit. Wir fahren Sie auf unseren Rollern, sicher. Wir fahren zu neunt auf zwei Rollern, fahren Sie ins Krankenhaus. Fahren sie sicher ins Krankenhaus. Ins KH, wie gesagt. Wir haben extra so Roller mit so einem Blaulicht vorne auf dem Lenker, wo wir sie über zwei Roller hinweg. Klappen die so dran. So drei Roller nebeneinander, um jemanden draufzulegen, um einfach damit zu fahren. Die dann selber noch eskortiert werden von zwei vorne und zwei hinten, die da fahren. Die sind so cool, ohne Scheiss. Also meine Cousine hat jetzt letztes Jahr Abi gemacht und was die erzählt aus ihrer Stufe ist fantastisch. Die unterstützen LGBTQ Community, die unterstützen die Umwelt, die gehen auf die Strasse, die machen jetzt alle ihr FSJ und haben alle eine gute Zeit dabei. Das ist alles total cool.
Und unentscheidend, was waren wir?
Wir waren auch super unpolitisch.
Und warum, das ist auch so ein Ding, wenn damals unsere Kinder...
Was heißt unpolitisch?
Also ich habe schon geschaut, dass die Wahlplakate, dass möglichst die sich nicht gegenseitig
überkleben, weil das fand ich unfair.
Also ich finde, unpolitisch finde ich schwach von dir, weil ich finde, ich habe mich schon sehr intensiv eingesetzt, damals für die Wahl. Du ja schon. Hat Kohl gewonnen, ja oder nein? Und Kohl hat es 2008 noch mal gewonnen in Evesberg. Nee, das stimmt schon. Du warst politisch, aber ich weiß, wenn unsere Kinder irgendwann mal fragen, was habt ihr denn dagegen gemacht gegen die Umweltkrise? Ach, ihr seid doch auf die Strasse gegangen, dann muss ich sagen, nee, es waren die nach uns. Wir haben da gesessen. Wir haben die nicht aufgehalten. Wir haben Yu-Gi-Oh! gespielt. Ich habe mindestens zwei Tweets von Luisa Neubauer geliked. Ich habe Beyblade gespielt. Ich habe maximale Plastik. Ich habe nicht mal Beyblade gespielt, ich habe mir selber Beyblades aus Legotechnik gebaut. Ich war noch eine Stufe unter den Bayblade-Kindern in der Schule.
Ich stand in der dritten Reihe, um den Kampf einer Bayblade um zweier Kreisel zu beobachten.
Ich war zu früh aus dem Unterricht gegangen, damit ich den Kampf zweier Kampfkreisel beobachten konnte.
Um den Oberstuflern dabei zuzuschauen, wie sie Bayblade spielen.
Wir haben mal einen Grill mitgebracht und haben in der Pause gegrillt und dachten, wir sind richtig cool. Bis irgendwann der Physiklehrer gesagt hat, Florentin, hast du eine Bratwurst dabei? Und dann musste ich die verzehren im Unterricht. Du wurdest dir gezwungen, die Bratwurst im Unterricht zu verzehren? Ich hatte eine Bratwurst in der Hosentasche und mein Lehrer hat geärbt. Was hier gerade für rebellische Geschichten ans Licht kommen. Nee, aber wenn man das so zusammenfasst, auf neun Jahre Schulzeit habe ich einmal gegrillt, einmal eine Bratwurst im Unterricht gegessen.
Beides nicht schlimm.
Nee, überhaupt wenn man das so zusammenfasst, auf neun Jahre Schulzeit habe ich einmal gegrillt, einmal eine Bratwurst im Unterricht gegessen. Beides nicht schlimm. Ne, überhaupt nicht schlimm. Und einmal war ich so nervig, dass ich nicht mit auf die Klassenfahrt gekommen wäre. Das ist nicht schlimm. Ich bin da mitgekommen, ich bin da mitgekommen. Die Warnung hat funktioniert. Ich habe mich dann zusammengerissen, ich habe mich am Riemen gerissen. Was war vorher los? Ich saß eh schon in der letzten Reihe und mit niemandem... Unterrichtsfach? Alle. Ich war ein 360-Grad-Störenfried in alle Richtungen. Mir völlig egal, alle Richtungen. Und ich wusste teilweise nicht mal, welches Unterrichtsfach gerade ist. Und jetzt ist auch siehe dir ein schlecht rollerfahrender Lappen geworden, der von Jugendlichen zurück auf die Beine gesetzt wird.
Aber ich glaube, da hätte ich mehr Kreativität gezeigt. Weil zum Beispiel, was wir gemacht haben, ist, wir haben so Seifenkisten gebaut in der Jugend oder wir hatten so einen Hang im Wald. Da sind wir so runtergefahren mit Schlitten und haben den modifiziert, irgendwie so einen Schlitten, der so auf Erde fährt und so. Also ich, hätten wir da mal so Elektroroller gehabt, wir hätten da was Cooles draus gebaut.
So drei Stück zusammengebaut, so einfach mal so eine Palette nehmen und da einfach mal drei Roller drunter klemmen und dann mit Segel oder was oder so ein Katamaran aus den Rollern.
Und dann zack auf den Rhein.
Und dann einfach direkt rein.
Oder genau, an die so Paddel dran gebaut, wie so ein Mississippi-Dampfer, schön und dann ein Boot gebaut damit und die seitlich. Da, glaube ich, hätten wir uns richtig ausgetobt. Wären wir uns richtig verletzt. Wir haben uns richtig hart verletzt. Was ich häufig gesehen habe, war jetzt Bierkasten, für Jugendlichen, Bierkasten auf den Roller gelegt, dann draufgesetzt und dann wie ein richtiger Roller. Also zu viert auf dem Kasten. Zu zweit draufgesetzt und dann die Hände in die Höhe an den Lenker, weil das ja dann doch, also es ist wie ein richtiger Roller mit viel zu hohem Lenker und dann aber drauf gefahren, sitzend auf diesem Roller gefahren. Sah super cool aus. Na gut, ich schwank jetzt nicht so super cool und super affig, aber ich finde das cool, was die da aus diesen Rollern machen. Das ist einfach so deren Objekt, das ist gerade die absolute, der Zeitgeist. Voller Zeitgeist, ne? Ich finde das nicht schlecht. Und ich glaube, das ist wirklich so, so fangen auch irgendwie Power Rangers an, wenn die es dann schaffen, wenn so ein ganzer Jahrgang irgendwie so 50 Roller zusammen kombiniert zu irgendwie so einer großen Kugel. Leim. Leim gegen Tier. Genau, die Oberstufe gegen Unterstufe. Du wachst es, in mein Territorium zu fahren, Leim. Tier, assemble! Kannst du hier... Einmal im Kreis rum. Leim, assemble! Los, Rollertacke! Und dann rollen die sich wie so ein grosser Igel einmal auf dich zu. Da kannst du nichts mehr machen. Nee, da kannst du nichts mehr machen. Das, glaube ich, hätten wir damals gemacht. Aber die Jugendnaturschutz sind cool, die machen coole Sachen. Thais ist eingegraben, in Akten, in Bibliotheken eingesperrt. Sie ist voller Staub, in uralten Archiven, wühlt sie gerade herum, sie wurde, sie hat sich verwandelt in Investiger Thais. Sie weiß, dass sie nur Dominions anrufen muss, ne? Naja, ich glaube, sie macht das schon gut, sie macht das schon gut und sie hat ihre Jugend zurück und es geht weiter. Ich finde das gut. Ich finde es auch gut. Aber wir krallen uns halt auch an sie als letzter Strohhalm, den wir zur Jugend haben. Ja, in gewisser Weise schon. Ey, mir ist das so peinlich, auch dass du mich da in diesen Dreck mitziehst, dass du da jetzt hingefallen bist und ich diese Jugendliche auf die Beine stellen müsste. Du siehst ja mich mit in diese, ich will nämlich nichts zu tun haben. Ich habe noch meine hippe Frisur und meine coolen Jugendshirts. Ich kleide mich noch wie ihr. Merkt ihr nicht, wie ich einer von euch sein will? Ich will nicht mit dir in Verbindung gebracht werden, der gar nicht mehr versucht, mit der Jugend mitzuhalten und dann vor dem Roller auf die Fresse fällst. Nein, spätestens wenn du gesiezt wirst, ist es vorbei. Es ist vorbei. Du musst jetzt auch mit Erwachsenen abhängen. Du musst jetzt auch einen schönen Pellogrinoino-Bianchi-Schömer mit einer Flasche Rosetta-Nachbarn vorbeischauen. Pellugrino ist eine Wassermarke. Du musst jetzt vor allem die Olympia schauen. Du musst Olympia schauen, das machen erwachsene Leute. Yes. Olympia, Medaillenspiegel, da kaufe ich mir mal die Beben. Gold. Wie viel Gold haben wir schon? Bronze. 15 Silber, drei Bronze und 180 Gold, yes, Deutschland, bestes Land. Wie man, muss man auch sagen, von Anfang an der Podcast, der Olympia am meisten abgefeiert hat, jetzt kommen sie alle an und sagen, wie toll das ist, diese ganzen Nischen, Sportler und Hobbyathleten. Nein, wir haben das schon 2009 oder so gut gefunden. Wir lieben Olympia, wir schauen uns aber auch nicht an. Wir schauen uns auch nicht an, manchmal an, wenn es läuft und man ist gerade am Fernseher. Ist es schon lustig, auf eine Art zuzugucken? Es ist lustig, ich schwanke immer zwischen, soll ich es ernst nehmen oder soll ich es so sehen, wie es ist? Vor allem, es gibt ja verschiedene Kategorien von Olympia, ich mag ja immer die Mannschaftssportarten, Basketball, Fußball, wo aber dann nicht die Nationalmannschaft spielt, sondern so eine Art Statistenmannschaft, die so ganz merkwürdig sind, die sind so, niemand kennt die, niemand interessiert sich für die.
Das nächste an unserem Vorschlag, dass man eine zufällig generierte, aus der Bevölkerung generierte Mannschaft, die in einer anderen ist.
Ja, irgendwie das ist so, ich meine, die können ja schon spielen.
Warum dürfen die nicht in der Nationalmannschaft spielen? Sind das Verbrecher, sind die vorbestraft und dürfen deswegen, oder was ist das, was vereint die als Gruppe? Ich verstehe das nicht ganz. Nein, die sind nur so jung. Deutschland schickt zum Beispiel einfach die U21-Wutmannschaften hin. Na gut, deswegen kenne ich die alle nicht. Deswegen die Bundesliga-Jungs und Mädels, die kenne ich alle, aber die kenne ich nicht. Die sind nicht zu jung, die sind ja auch viele in der Bundesliga. Ja, aber da hätte ich schon, also das sind jetzt nicht so, ja klar. Hier ist so ein Gödel und so ein Polizki. Gödel, der einzige Name, der bis lange in der Folge gefallen ist. Die würde ich schon erkennen. Die würde ich schon erkennen. Aber es ist immer merkwürdig. Es ist irgendwie so merkwürdig, weil man hat so das Gefühl, wenn die Fussball spielen, mögen es alle, wenn die Fussball spielen, ist es irgendwie uncool. Das guckt man nicht an. Für mich als Laie überhaupt kein Unterschied, null Unterschied. Aber so als draufguckt, man hat das Gefühl, dass selbst der härteste Fussballfan die nicht cool finden darf. Das ist so wie die Parallelklasse irgendwie so, irgendwie so wie die zweite Besetzung beim Theaterstück. Die sind ja richtig. Warum denn nicht? Irgendwie so, das ist halt so die No-Name-Lidl-Marke so. Ja, aber es ist dasselbe. Es ist ein bisschen Off-Brand. Ja, nee, irgendwie so. Man kann es nicht so erklären, aber ich weiß es nicht. Ja, schon, es ist ein bisschen Off-Brand. In der Ringe auch, die auf dem dem Klick-Trikot noch kleben, irgendwo. Dieses Dabeisein ist alles. Das hat Olympia ein bisschen kaputt gemacht. Seitdem Dabeisein alles ist, ist ja Gewinnen nichts. Das ist der zweite Teil dieses Spruchs, der oft nicht zitiert wird. Dabeisein ist alles, Gewinnen ist nichts. Ich jetzt als Logiker habe diesen Satz mir vorgenommen und überlegt, was sagt das denn in der ganzen Implikationen aus? Was sind die Implikationen, die sich daraus ergeben? Sehr gut. Was ist das Fazit? Wenn Gewinnen alles, wenn Dabeisein alles ist, was bleibt denn dann noch übrig? Das ist meine Frage. Das ist eine gute Frage, das ist eine verdammt gute Frage. Das ist meine Frage. Vielleicht müssen wir sagen, Dabeisein ist fast alles. Dabeisein ist 80%. 20% ist, 18% ist Gewinn, 2% ist nicht verletzt werden. Das ist ja blöd. Das wäre doof. Das wäre blöd. Vor allem bei jedem Verletzten haben wir noch das andere Turnier, wo man dann mitmacht. Ja, das stimmt. Oder du kannst Kommentator werden. Sind Sie so einen Job gekommen? Ja. Ich bin damals mit voller Wucht gegen das Tor gelaufen. Ich renne da hin, der Ball kommt von links, weder weniger aus dem Nichts, ich habe den gar nicht gesehen. Ich gucke immer nach vorne, wenn ich renne. Jeder Mensch guckt meistens nur nach vorne. Ich gucke nach vorne, um gerade eben nicht ins Tor zu laufen. Dann kommt aber der Ball von links angesaust, eine Flanke. Ich sehe ihn noch im letzten Moment, denke mir, wo
fliegt der denn hin, wo hat der denn wieder hingeschossen?
Mit dem Effet, mit dem ganzen
Effet. Gödl ist
eh dafür bekannt, dass er einfach irgendwo
Hauptsache in die richtige Richtung.
Naja, also auf jeden Fall sehe ich
den ankommenden Ball und
ich springe wie ein Wilder.
Also aus dem Sprint
heraus gehe ich dann nochmal wirklich
mit beiden Füssen auf dem Boden
in die Hocke, spring
Vielen Dank. Ich springe wie ein Wilder. Also aus dem Sprint heraus gehe ich dann nochmal wirklich mit beiden Füssen auf dem Boden in die Hocke, springe tief, richtig tief und dann ganz aus dem Lauf. Ich drücke mich richtig ab und ich gebe richtig Kraft in die Beine, richtig Kraft in die Beine. Alles was Sie haben. Ich lege meine Hände auf die Knie vorne drauf, um auch mit den Armen noch mehr Kraft auf die Beine zu geben. Ich stosse mich also ab, der Rasen gibt quasi nach. Das hat er geregelt, das muss er dazu sagen, das hat er geregelt. Der Rasen gibt ein bisschen nach, der Rasen löst sich von seinem Erduntergrund, ich habe aber trotzdem noch ordentliche Kraft drauf. Ich springe also ab, dadurch, dass der Rasen sich aber löst ein bisschen, verliere ich die Kontrolle, schleudere mehr nach vorne, als dass ich springe. Unkontrolliert, in Metern Höhe. Unkontrolliert, in einem Meter Höhe. Also die Kraft, die ich angesammelt hatte durch meine Technik, die ich eigentlich geplant hatte, dass sie mich nach oben wirft, schleudert mich jetzt kerzengerade nach vorne in einem Meter Höhe. Ich sehe also, wie der Rasen unter meinen Augen vorbeischnellt mit halsbrächerischer Geschwindigkeit. Ich habe sämtliche Kontrolle über meinen Körper verloren. Was machen die Gegenspieler zu dieser Zeit? Die Gegenspieler stehen mit Erstaunen, schauen diesem Spektakel zu. Aber viele versuchen auch außer Gefahr zu kommen. Der eine versucht, den Ball mit der Hand zu fangen, während der andere versucht, ihm die Hand festzuhalten, während er sagt, nein, Hand ist verboten, Hand ist verboten, versucht sein Mitspieler also die Hand festzuhalten. Ich weiß nicht, ob das Berufsspieler sind oder nicht. Aber egal, auf jeden Fall, ich lasse mich davon gar nicht ablenken, weil ich habe nur diesen Rasen vor Augen, der wirklich wie ein, stellen Sie sich vor, wir würden so einen Film gucken und der Abspann in zehnfacher Geschwindigkeit rasst. Ich durche mir das ganze Zeit schon vorzustellen, das fällt mir nicht so ein, an ihm vorbei. Und ich fliege also und denke mir, nein, du musst trotzdem nach oben gucken, du weißt ja nicht, wo der Ball ist, wo der sich durch diese ganzen Effee-Effekte, die fliegen irgendwo hin. Ich gucke also noch mal nach oben, sehe nicht den Ball, sondern den Pfosten des Tors, das Aluminium. Nein, nein. Fast mit gleicher Geschwindigkeit auf mich zurauschen, wie ich. Das passiert genau das, was Sie am Anfang mal gesagt haben, was hier ist. Also jetzt, ich rausche auf das Aluminium zu, das Aluminium rauscht mir mit gleicher Geschwindigkeit entgegen, ich schlag also mit doppelter Geschwindigkeit keine Zeit mehr die Hände in die Höhe zu heben, die ich ja an meine Seiten... Keine Zeit mehr, sich zu fragen, warum der Pfosten auch auf mich zu schnell ist. Die Arme hatte ich zu dem Zeitpunkt an meine Hüften gepresst, um den Luftwiderstand zu verringern.
Ich schiesse also auf das Aluminium vor und es kommt mir entgegen und trifft mich am Kopf mit einer solchen Geschwindigkeit, einer solchen Härte, dass der gesamte Torbogen klappert, vibriert, scheppert und rattert und mich quasi ins Tor katapultiert, vom Pfosten ins Tor katapultiert, der Ball lange im Aus, ich im Tor, schwer verletzt, Karriere beendet. Und deswegen lassen wir keine Leihen spielen mehr. Ja, aber damals lief das anders. Ich weiß noch, damals, wann war das? Ist nicht so wichtig. War 96? Immer diese, wie diese alten Menschen, die immer Geschichten erzählen und sich an diesen kleinen Details immer aufhängen. Und man denkt, I don't fucking care. Dann läuft es der Inhalt der Irre wahnsinnig interessant, aber dann hängen sich so die Details auf. Machen wir das, Manfred, 89? Nein, nee, das war ja noch vor. Da war die Katrin doch dabei, die ist doch gestorben, 96. Genau, die 96. Nee, aber war Katrin, war es nicht Clara, die dabei war. Und man sitzt daneben und denkt, was ist passiert? Genauso ein Phänomen, das mich auch immer wieder begeistert ist, wenn jemand irgendwas erklärt, vor allem wenn jemand den Unterschied zwischen zwei Dingen erklärt, aber diese Begriffe konstant miteinander verwechselt. Oh Gott. Also es gibt mehrere an von Torf, es gibt Weisstorf und Schwarztorf. Weisstorf ist der oben, ne Weisstorf sag ich, Schwarztorf ist, habe ich jetzt Weisstorf, Quatsch, Schwarztorf meine ich, der ist dichter, weil weniger Sauerstoff da rankommt. Jetzt ist das Video und mehr Sauerstoff. Wenn ich erkläre, warum Scheiben beschlagen, dann passiert das genau das. Und die ganze Zeit... Warme Luft kann Wasser aufnehmen. Du meinst kalte Luft. Ja. Genau. Der andere, dem man es erklärt, korrigiert einen. Weiß es besser. Du meinst warme Luft. Ja, und irgendwann denkt man so, wer erklärt dir wem was und warum habe ich es dir in the first place erklärt, wenn du mir das besser erklären kannst.
Und am Ende denkt man sich, ich weiß jetzt weniger, als ich davor wusste.
Nicht nur habe ich nichts gelernt, der ist zu mir in die Bibliothek gekommen, hat die Kisten umgeworfen, hat die Bücher rausgerissen und ist wieder gegangen.
Ich bin verwirrter, als ich davor war.
Schwarztoff. Ach, Weisthoff.
Also Weisthoff ist der, der tiefer liegt mit weniger Sauerstoff. Was habe ich jetzt gesagt? Weiß ich nicht. Was habe ich gesagt? Ich meine, nochmal diese Floskel, die man so hat, wenn man sich korrigiert. Weisthoff sag ich schon. Jetzt Quatsch. Jetzt sag ich schon Weisthoff.orf ist der Tier. Auch diese entlarvende Frage.
Was habe ich gesagt?
Eine andere, weiß ich nicht.
Weiß ich nicht, habe ich so gehört.
Ich habe die vier Wörter davor, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Meine Aufmerksamkeit ist auf unter vier Wörter zusammengeschrumpft.
Wenn du was erzählst, kriegst du zwei Wörter.
Du fragst mich nach zwei Wörtern, was passiert ist.
Ich kann es nicht sagen. Alles weitere nicht. Das ist wahnsinnig frustrierend, aber auch toll. Einfach mal, wenn man das erklärt, einfach mal schauen, wie hart kann man jemanden verwirren. These. Bisschen doofe These, aber ich sage trotzdem mal, weil es ist ja auch so ein bisschen so ein Podcast. Wir sprechen, wie andere denken. Hypothese oder nur These? Nee, die These. Okay. Deutsche erzählen Geschichten schlechter. Als? Zum Beispiel Amerikaner, wo der Tale, den man erzählt, the Tale, the Tale, the Tale, ja schon deutlich mehr in der Geschichte des Landes verankert ist. Ja. Dieses, man erzählt sich ein Tale, man erzählt sich eine Geschichte.
In Deutschland erzählt man sich keine Tales.
Die Geschichte ist nicht so krass verbreitet in der Kultur des Landes.
Hier wird eher pragmatisch gesagt.
Eher eine Literaturgesellschaft vielleicht, wo man Sachen eher aufschreibt.
So, schreib es mir auf.
Schreib es mal auf. Ist eigentlich gar nicht schlecht, wenn jemand etwas erzählt, sagt, du pass auf, schreib es mir auf. Schreib es mir auf. Ist eigentlich gar nicht schlecht, wenn jemand
dir was erzählt, sagt, du pass auf, schreib es mir auf.
Schreib mir ein SMS.
Mal es mir auf. Weil du, eigentlich
ist Schreiben der respektvollere Umgang,
weil du überlegst dir die Wörter genau, du überlegst
dir, was ich sagen will, in welche Reihenfolge, sag ich vielleicht
erst das mit dem Rasen
und sag dann den Unfall oder
steige ich im Krankenhaus ein und
mache eine Rückblende und dann kannst du das Ganze nochmal ganz anders darstellen. Pass auf, mach einen Film daraus. Du, mach einen Kurzfilm. Du, mach einen wirklich ganz einfach gemacht. Mit der Handykamera kann das heutzutage. Kann man heutzutage alles. Kann man heutzutage superleichten Film machen. Du, iMovie ist programmiert. Hast du auf dem Desktop. Schau mal nach. Ich hasse es immer, wenn man nach neuen Kameras
guckt und so auf das Internet, dieses Internetforum,
ach, mit einer iPhone-Kamera braucht man
ja auch gar keine gute Kamera mehr.
Man denkt so, ich war bereit,
jetzt Geld dafür auszugeben für diesen Quatsch.
Ich will mich ja von anderen
Menschen abheben. Ich will dieses
Loch in meinem Leben füllen
mit Konsum. Ich will die neue Phase.
Dass diese Foren das nicht checken, dass man auch mal irrationale Entscheidungen treffen kann. Nee, das macht ja keinen Sinn gerade. Hast du dir denn genau überlegt? Du hast ja im Laptop die Webcam, die ist super. Also die reicht ja wunderbar. Überhaupt keinem. Aber ich will was kaufen, ich will es auspacken, ich will es benutzen, kurz benutzen und dann liegen lassen. Du hast weniger Megapixel bei der Kamera und das kostet es dreifache. Ich will was kaufen! Das ist schon auch wichtig, dass man ab und zu so mal so Quatsch kauft, um einfach so ein bisschen dieses Loch zu füllen. Ich kaufe viel zu wenig, fällt mir immer wieder auf. Es ist schwierig. Aber das sage ich häufig, du bist der unmaterialistischste Mensch, den ich kenne. Du, ich habe ein Riesenproblem. Guck mal, hier meine Kamera bei meinem Handy. Hier, so sieht es aus. Komplett gebrochene Linse, komplett kaputt rausgebrochen. Ich war jetzt im Urlaub, sämtliche Urlaubsfotos, unbrauchbar, sämtliche Urlaubsfotos. Aber gut, dass du wie viele Fotos gemacht hast, einfach so, obwohl du weißt, dass die Kamera kaputt ist? Ja, was sollst du denn machen, wenn jemand sagt, hey, machst du ein Gruppenfoto und du weißt, meine Kamera ist kaputt, machst du dann keine? Sagen, kann das einer von euch machen, weil ich habe keine Kamera. Nein, das ist drei Level über meinem sozialen Niveau. Das ist soziale Interaktion sieben, ich habe soziale Interaktion zwei. Und dann machst du halt ein Foto und weißt, na, lächeln, du weißt, das wird furchtbar, das kann niemand verwenden, das kann einfach niemand verwenden.
Dieses Bild, dann schickst du es rum und alle, komisch, ist da irgendwas schwarz dran?
Nee, nee, nee, das kann man doch bearbeiten, heutzutage kann man ja alles bearbeiten.
Null Autofokus, unscharf, ganz furchtbar.
Ja, ist doof.
Ja, aber was soll ich machen?
Nee, habe ich dir schon mal gesagt, weil eine Kamera an seinem Handy ist ja nicht nur für dich, ist ja auch für alle Menschen in deinem Umfeld, weil du bist ja der Dokumentarfilmer der Leute in deinem Umfeld.
Ja, du beschwerst dich immer, dass ich keine Fotos von dir mache.
Niemand macht Fotos von mir. Ich bin der mit dem neuesten Handy. E-Tour-Backstage, immer so mega geile Fotos von mir, wie ich da cool Backstage sitze, wie ich da irgendwie mit dem Produzenten rede, wie ich nochmal die Scheinwerfer gucke, wo ich nochmal schaue, sind die Scheinwerfer okay, wie ich persönlich die Gäste auch nochmal begrüsse, wo ich nochmal gucke auf die Bühne, wie sieht es mit der Sicherheit aus. Und alles super cool dokumentiert, wo gegen Stefan einmal kurz, wenn er irgendwie sich am Automaten was holt, unscharf, Autofokus, Fokus, keine Hose an, schlechtester Zeitpunkt ever, ja, das sind die Fotos, die du machst. Beugt sich gerade so seitlich über, versucht so unten durch die Klappe reinzugreifen, weil sein KitKat festhängt. Und ich so, musst du das jetzt von der Handys? Hilf mir, wie gesagt, hilf mir. Mit diesem, ach komm, hilf mir, Blick. Aber das ist bei allen Menschen so in meinem Umfeld. Alle haben diese alten Handys, weil die besonders cool tun wollen. Und nee, ich brauche ja kein neues Handy. Nein, ihr braucht keine neuen Handys, ich brauche eure neuen Handys. Okay. Deswegen verschenkst du mittlerweile auch sehr... Ich verschenke iPhone-12s. Einfach jedem, damit du gute Fotos verniehst. Ja. Ja, stimmt, dann ist das schlecht. Jeder braucht einen Anwaltsfreund oder Anwältin, jeder braucht eine oder einen Arztfreund und Fotograf, Fotografin. Das ist nämlich der andere Punkt. Du brauchst jemanden, der dein Leben dokumentieren kann für Instagram, für die sozialen Medien, denn darum geht es doch am Ende des Tages. Ja, stimmt schon, aber ich bin auch großer Fan von den modernen Filtern, die glaube ich irgendwann, also angenommen, du machst ein gutes Foto von mir, Backstage, wie ich irgendwie gerade irgendwie, keine Ahnung, manchmal sind da.
Ich bin mir Ärger, beim Comedy Store. Das ist man einmal in seinem Leben, ne, Comedy-Seller. Und du hast, und ich habe am Ende des Tages, das habe ich auch immer noch hochgeladen, ein verschwommenes Bild, komplett verschwommen, habe ich hochgeladen bei Instagram, weil es das einzige gebrauchbare Bild war. Und du hast die besten Bilder, wie du so Louis-Siecker-artig da rausläufst, alles passt genau. Und ich habe ein verschwommenes Bild kam bei mir raus. Einmal ist ja nicht mit der modernen Filtertechnik, dass wenn du ein cooles Bild von mir machst, du dann einfach dich da reintun kannst. Dass du einfach sagst, Copy, Paste, ersetze Florentin durch mich und dann bist du da drin. Das ist doch alles möglich, weil es gibt ja Filter, wo du aussiehst wie ein Hund und eine Biene und irgendwann kannst du ja die Filter einfach von dir selber auf Leute draufsetzen. Und dann kannst du einfach Fotos von anderen Leuten machen, mit denen du im Urlaub bist, machst ein Foto von denen am Strand, setzt dir da ein Gesicht drauf, easy. Easy, da un. Oder dein Körper halt, oder halt nur Gesicht, oder eins vorbei. Nee, nur Gesicht, das wird ja schon reichen. Ja, finde ich ganz gut. Und mein ganzer Account ist offensichtlich geschockt. Jedes Bild ist offensichtlich falsch, es wird immer unrealistischer. Du am Strand mit Bikini, ich neben Jeff Bezos im All und so und alle, okay, Stefan, wir wissen, dass du Fotoschauen. Hast du das verfolgt, du als großer Astronomie affiner Experte? Ich als großer, das ging dir aber nicht leicht über die Lippen, lass dir sagen. Das gefällt dir nicht. Alles in mir hat sich gesträumt, als mir das eiskaltet Rücken runtergelaufen. Du als großer Astronomie. Ah, mein Zahnfleisch hat wirklich geschmerzt, als ich das über die Lippen bringen musste. Wow! Nee, ich als Weltraum-Fan. Nee, ich muss schon sagen, dass ich das nicht verfolgt habe. Nee, Jeff Bezos ist mir wohl auch aufgefallen, dass der da schon mal dran war an diesem Thema. Und jetzt ist er ja mit der Rakete ins, in Richtung all und dann eben all und dann zurück und dann wieder hier. Das war spannend, weil ja bislang Privatpersonen nicht ins all. Aber es ist der Preis, was kostet der Spaß? Jetzt sag mal, jetzt leg mal was, schreib mal was auf den Tisch. Nimm mal deinen Lamy und schreib mal was auf den Tisch. Lass mich kurz überschlagen, was man braucht. Benzinkoste, Rakete, Startrampe, vielleicht irgendwie Snacks für unterwegs. Aber dann kannst du gegenrechnen, Medien, also Werben kosten, vielleicht so Erdnuss, Schokolinsen oder sowas. Ja, die schmelzen, aber wenn du eine Linse hast, dann bleibt die geschmolzte Schokolade ja drin. Weil ich dachte, wenn die geschmolzte Schokolade in Instrumente geht oder so. Zwölf Millionen. Zwölf, ach ja. Zwölf Millionen. Zwölf Millionen. Zwölf Millionen. Brauchst aber einen guten Werbedien mit Red Bull, musst das Logo drauf machen. Und du musst irgendwie gucken, dass du es von der Steuer absetzen kannst. Dass du sagst, er ist ja eigentlich Arbeitsweg, also ist ja Pendler im Grunde. Von Goslar bis Bad Gandersheim übers All geflogen? Ja, ja, wie gesagt, mein Freund Rudi meinte, das ging schneller und ich könnte da ein bisschen Zeit sparen. Aber sie können noch die S3 nehmen. Ja, ja, ja, klar. Du hast bei der Estimt,. Du musst halt umsteigen in Rudersbach. Und da ist es oft das Problem, dass die Taktung nicht genau gleich ist. Und dann kommst du halt um 40 an und musst bis 12 warten. Also musst du halt 32 Minuten warten. Und deswegen meine Rudi, wenn man jetzt die Erdumlaufbahn sich anschaut und die Rotation der Erde, dann rotiert die ja genau sozusagen Richtung Gondelsberg.
Das heißt, wenn du im richtigen Moment in die in die Erdumlaufbahn eintrittst und dann den Hitzeschild aktivierst,
kommst du ja technisch gesehen vor der S3 eigentlich in Rodelsbach an und kannst dann noch die frühere S-Bahn nehmen und bist schneller da.
Kostet halt ein bisschen mehr.
Wie viel haben Sie bezahlt?
Na, schauen Sie.
Also schauen Sie, ich bin ungefähr 40 Minuten früher gekommen.
In der Zeit habe ich locker drei, vier Formulare ausgefüllt, ich habe zwei Kunden betreut.
12 Millionen.
12 Millionen? Ich hatte recht.
Es hat 12 Millionen gekostet. Naja, aber kann man da was machen? Ich rechne mir kurz ein, was sie zurückbekommen. Sie sind der einzige Mensch, die noch so einen Taschenrechner haben. 8,60 Euro kann ich ihnen zurückerstatten. Ah, immerhin. Immerhin. Ich bin immer sauer auf meine Steuerberaterin, jedes Mal. Ich koche vor Wut, ich laufe blass an. Rasend hast du vorhin gesagt. Ich bin rasend. Ja? Ich koche vor Wut und rufe sie dann immer wütend an, wenn da so eine Steuerbescheinigung kommt oder sowas. Und dann erklärt sie mir das immer, nimmt mir jegliche Wut, jeglicher Wind aus den Segeln, und dann denke ich mir, ja, das macht einen mega Job. Jedes Mal das Gleiche, aber ich lerne es nicht, ihr einfach zu trauen. Ich denke jedes Mal, das ist doch viel zu viel, du holst zu wenig raus, das kann doch alles nicht sein, wie kann das sein, das kann nicht sein. So ist es dann doch. Und dann rufe ich sie an, bleich, verbut. Ich bin doch Autor, ich kann gut schreiben, ich habe einen guten Wortschatz, da muss doch mehr drin sein. Da muss doch mehr was drin sein. Ich kann nicht mehr haben. Das kann doch jetzt nicht sein. Ich will mehr haben. Ich will mehr haben. Aber ganz kurz, Astronaut sein ist ein legendär schwieriger Beruf. Du musst dich an wahnsinnig viele Regeln halten. Du darfst nicht schwanger sein, du darfst nicht keine dünnen Knochen haben, du musst super gut ausgebildet sein, du musst wissen im richtigen Moment, was machst du, du darfst halt keine Erdnüsse mit an Bord nehmen. Du musst Englisch sprechen können. Du musst Englisch sprechen können, du musst diverse fiktive Aliensprachen beherrschen, falls, man weiss ja nie, so, du darfst keine Chips mitnehmen, du musst irgendwie gucken, dass du dich mit Tieren auskennst. Manchmal sind Ameisen mit an Bord, manchmal sind Affen mit an Bord, verschiedene Tests mit Pflanzen, die versuchen Gemüse anzubauen im Weltall, du musst dich damit auskennen, botanisch interessiert sein, du darfst keine Nicknacks mit an Bord nehmen, also verschiedene Regeln, die du dich halten musst. Wenn du aber aber sagst, ich fliege jetzt privat, und du sagst, ich will jetzt aber meinen Slushy mitnehmen, und die sagen, nein, das können sie nicht, Herr Bezos, wenn das in die Instrumente geht, das verklebt, dann so, Entschuldigung, wer bezahlt hier Wien gerade eigentlich? Wer bezahlt hier? Hier ist ein Check von 12 Millionen Euro. Ich glaube, ich kann mitnehmen, was ich will. Und dann kannst du ja machen, was du willst. Keine Ahnung von gar nichts. Ich muss nicht in diese Röhre. Ich ess Slashy im Weltraum. Ja. Ich lecke die ganze Rakete ab, nachdem wir wieder gelandet sind auf der Erde, um zu gucken, wie der Weltraum schmeckt. Können Sie, können Sie vielleicht. Ja, Herr Bezos will noch wissen, wie der Weltraum schmeckt. Geben Sie mir auch fünf Minuten. Kann ich meinen Lutscher, kann ich so einen Chubachubs-Lutscher aus dem Fenster halten? Der Rakete hat kein Fenster. Na, aber wenn ich es kurz raushalte und was für den Sternenstaub, schreib es auf Fernstehen und schreib es auf Playstation 2, GTA 3 und ich habe da einen Spielstern, wo ich schon dieses coole Auto habe. Vielleicht können Sie das auch noch da rein programmieren. Ich würde gerne meinen Lutscher aus dem Fenster halten, um den Sternenstaub einzufangen. Wie ist der, oder? Fliegen wir durch Sternenstaub? Sternenstaub. Nein, Herr Bezos, wir haben keinen Sternenstaub. Wir machen eine Rute durch Sternenstaub. Oh mein Gott. Und dann nehme ich mit dem Lutscher das auf. Oder kennen Sie diese Lutscher, wo man so diese Brause dann drin hat? Diese kleine, pritzelige Brause. Das mache ich nur in ein schwarzes Loch. Ich will es tunken in ein schwarzes Loch. Genau. Also erst in die Brause, dann ablecken und dann diesen Fuss nochmal in ein schwarzes Loch. Geht das?
Ich musste nur nicht so lachen, wo du gerade sagst, fiktive Alien-Sprachen. Ich muss mich wirklich zusammenreißen. Ich war, okay, halte ich fest, in der Sauna. Ja, grosser Saunabereich.
Wow!
Ich war da und dann gibt es da halt den normalen Saunabereich, den, wie es normalerweise läuft, Pool und so. Und dann gab es einen sehr speziellen, ein Laconium heißt das, glaube ich. Das ist so ein Ort, das ist sehr so Dampfsaunamässig. Man gesetzt sich da einfach rein und davor standen dann aber so Peelings, womit man nicht so einschmiert und so. Habe ich erst nicht verstanden, habe ich dann andere Leute beobachtet, die das gemacht haben, habe mir dann rausgegangen und wieder habe mir eins genommen. Dann schmiert man den ganzen Körper ein und der wird dann super weich und samtlich und toll. So, und man fühlt sich gut. Und dann war das von Peeling und das war Kaffee, Salz, aber also Sohle und so und ich glaube noch keine Ahnung, auch noch Honig oder sowas. Auf jeden Fall, die Farbe, die bestimmte Farbe war schwarz, wegen des Kaffeepulvers, was da drin war. So, da ist man da rein und alle haben sich in diesem schwarzen Zeug eingemacht. Und jetzt kommt's, da lief Musik. In der Sauna lief Musik, so schöne Klänge, so Spa-Klänge liefen dann da, ruhige Musik.
Dann war das eine Lied vorbei und ich bin mittendrin, dabei mich in diesem schwarzen Ding Leben zu suhlen. Und in dem Moment endet sich der Soundtrack und der nächste Track beginnt und es fängt an, der Soundtrack von Arrival. Ja, und ich wusste, und es ist nicht der Ort, wo man lachen sollte, weil andere und nackte Menschen reinkommen, rausgehen und es ist so ein Ort, grösster bei sich Erwachsenheit, bei sich sein, kein Gekicher, aber es fing der fucking Soundtrack an, über den Film mit den grossen schwarzen Alienwesen und wir haben uns halt einfach eingeschmiert, diesem schwarzen Zeug. Und dann, es war halt hilarious, es war der merkwürdigste Ort mit den merkwürdigsten Menschen, die merkwürdigst an sich rumgemodelt haben und dann diesen Leben auf sich geschmiert haben. Und dann ging diese Arrival-Musik an und man dachte, das ist die unwirklichste, unerdmässigste Experience, die ich je in meinem Leben hatte. Das ist die schlechteste Deleted-Scene, die ich je gesehen habe. Das ist so ein Scheiß-Deleted-Scene. Wir alle mit unseren vielen Gliedern haben uns also eingeschmiert in diesem Zeug und lief auf Arrival. Ich fand es unglaublich gut. Aber da muss man auch nochmal fragen, weil es gibt ja die grundsätzliche medizinische Devise, hör auf deinen Körper. Aber stimmt das wirklich? Weil zum Beispiel eine Sauna, wenn ich in eine Sauna gehe, sage ich nach zwei Minuten, mir ist warm. Mein Körper sagt, ich würde gerne gehen. Raus, raus, raus. Ich würde gerne gehen, brauche. Aber man sagt, nein, man muss da durch und man muss heiß und man muss schwitzen und Sauna ist gut für einen. Also soll man jetzt auf seinen Körper hören oder nicht? Hör auf deinen Körper, aber du musst halt wissen, dein Körper ist halt auch ein ungeduldiges Arschloch. Ja, und ist ein bisschen weinerlich. Weinerliches ungeduldigst Ding. Nee, so warm. Nee. Ja, genau, aber lass ihn mal jetzt mal im eisekalten Wasser ein bisschen länger drin, dann stößt er Hormone aus. Du bist aber dann nicht mit dem schwarzen Zeug ins Wasser gegangen. Nee, das ist ja ein Laconium, hörst du mir da nicht zu. Im Laconium hat jeder diese Brausen und kann sich an seinem Platz noch abbrausen. Mit Wasser? Normalem Wasser. Oder kalten Wasser? Normalem Wasser. Salzwasser? Normalem Süsswasser. Okay. Wie süss, wie süss. Wollte gerade sagen, Normalheit. Das ist ja nicht süss. Süsswasser ist, man hat ein bisschen überkompensiert beim Namen. Gut, es ist schon das Gegenteil von Salzwasser, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht süss. Ja, wenn mir jemand vor meiner Geburt sagt, willst du ein Süsswasserfisch oder ein Salzwasserfisch sein, sage ich, sign me in Süsswasser. Ich will den ganzen Tag in süssem, süssem Wasser rumschneiden. Aber du bist enttäuscht, weil das Wasser eigentlich normales Wasser ist. Das schmeckt ganz normal. Ja, das ist die Mitte. Das ist die Mitte. Ja, das ist die Mitte. Wir nennen die Mitte süss. Nein, das ist normal. Wir nennen die Mitte süss, weil es das Gegenteil von salzisch ist. Wenn nicht jemand bei Popcorn fragt, süss oder salzig, du nimmst süss und das ist einfach normal. Plain Popcorn. Plain. Nein, das ist nicht süss. Das ist Mais gepoppt. Vor allem, wir haben ein Wort dafür. Wasser. Salzwasser und Wasser. Es ist einfach da. Es ist da. Es ist da. Es braucht kein Add-on. Aber verrückt, dass es Salzwasser da nochmal separat gibt. Also ich meine, es könnte ja Süsswasser geben. Halt einfach so, weil es gibt ja auch so Zuckerfrüben. Ja. Aber du bist jetzt ein Saunatyp, oder was? Ich war da jetzt ein paar Mal und es hat mir wirklich viel Spaß gemacht gemacht und so. Ich, äh, ist ganz cool, ist auch in meinem Fitnessstudio, wo ich auch Sport mache, heißt, und es ist total geil, weil man ja, wenn man danach da irgendwie noch runterkommt und so und nach dem Sport irgendwie sich in so warme Becken legt, ist es ganz geil halt, dass man so doppelt Body Positivity mitbekommt. Zum einen lernt man, mit seinem nackten, ekligen Körper umzugehen, weil man ja da rumläuft, nackt, in diesem Sauna-Bereich. Heißt, du lernst da irgendwie mit deinem Körper im Reinen zu sein. Alle sind ja da im Reinen. Das ist irgendwie, das beträgt sich auch, das ist gut. Auf der anderen Seite tust du aber auch was für deinen Körper, weil du davor Sport machst. Heißt, du hast so ultimativ, lernst du deinen Körper mögen. Und das so exponentiell, weil dir von beiden Seiten näherst du dich ja dem grünen Bereich. Aber fängst du dann nicht irgendwann an, immer weniger Sport zu machen? Weil du sagst, ich fühle mich immer wohler in meinem Körper und habe immer weniger Motivation, mich zu verändern. Ich habe immer weniger Skrupel, das der Öffentlichkeit zu zeigen. Und ich sehe hier eine Menge, die fetter sind als ich, von daher kein Problem. Ist das nicht eigentlich kontraproduktiv? Kann auch kontraproduktiv sein. Solange aber mein Mental Health da voll am Start ist und es mir sehr gut geht dabei, denke ich mir, warum nicht? Ich bin bei Saunen, ich war nicht oft in meinem Leben in Saunen, aber ich bin immer unter Null rausgekommen. Also klar, Sauna ist entspannt und super und cool, aber wenn ich mir die gesamte Aktivität anschaue und aufrechne, hinfahren, Parkplatz finden, hinlaufen, regnen, Ticket, was wollen sie, keine Ahnung, was kostet das, Kleingeld, Geldbeutel, Spind, auf, hin, Münze rein, rein, oh nass, ich bin, ist nass, hinten raus, oh, wo bin ich nicht hin, links, rechts, was bedeuten die Farben, welches Becken zuerst, hin, und all das, und danach, dann bist du entspannt, und danach wieder, Föhn, oh, heiß, Kopfhaut schmerzt, was bedeuten die Farben, wo sind meine, wo sind meine Sachen, oh, jetzt ist nass, jetzt ziehe ich mir nass die Jeans an, das geht nicht, nasse Socken, oh und wenn ich dann am Ende wieder irgendwie zu Hause sitze und mir denke, jetzt mal stricken und dann deine Beleitung so, du bist der dümmste Mensch, du bist farbenblind, wenn du mich noch einmal fragst, was die Farben bedeuten, du bist weinerlich, du fönst deine Haare viel zu lange, ich mach Schluss.
Und am Ende denke ich mir, eigentlich bin ich negativ rausgegangen.
Eigentlich war der ganze Stress, dahin zu kommen, hat es nicht wettgemacht.
Pass auf, jetzt ist es ja, wie ich gerade meinte, auch mein Fitnessstudio.